so I have a question for you which is
better grass-fed or organic let's say
you're at the grocery store and they
don't have grass-fed in organic together
you see your eggs it might say pasture
raised which is basically out there on
the in the grass and then but it doesn't
say organic and then another one says
organic which one would you pick or
let's say for example you're buying beef
and there's grass-fed and there's
organic but there's not a product that
says grass-fed organic which one are you
gonna pick that's what we want to talk
about now when you buy beef that's
grass-fed you have to realize there's no
legal definition of grass-fed so you
don't know how long that cow has been
fed grass it could be several months it
could be a year you don't know what's
more important than grass-fed is is it
grass-finished okay because if it
doesn't say grass-finished it's going to
be grain finished now the difference
between a cow that's been fed grains
versus grass is quite significant
especially in the omega 3 and 6 fatty
acids so omega-6 fatty acids are the
ones that tend to be more inflammatory
omega-3 fatty acids are more
anti-inflammatory and grain-fed beef has
about a 20 to 1 ratio very very heavy on
the omega-6 fatty acids versus the
grass-fed beef is like a two-to-one so
it's it's a better ratio and then we
have something called sealing which is
really good for the heart for energy and
it's even anti-cancer and it's 2 to 3
times more in the grass-fed the
grass-fed beef also has a lot more
vitamin A a lot more vitamin E 2 to 4
times more so that's grass-fed let's
talk about organic when something says
it's a hundred percent certified organic
it's a hundred percent if something says
it's just organic it's 95 to 99 percent
organic now what does organic mean it
means without pesticides herbicides
fungicides and insecticides also if
something is organic it's not gonna have
antibiotics or hormones or bio solids
okay now if you look up a definition of
a bio solid it says nutrient-rich
organic byproduct okay like what is that
aka sewage sludge yes they feed animals
sewage sludge there's a real interesting
book that I was reading on this is
called toxic sludge is good for you this
is all about the Public Relation
industry and how they made sewage sludge
sound a lot better because bow solids
really sound safe and healthy because
it's a nutrient-rich organic byproduct
right yeah well they feed the animals
this stuff okay they put it into the
soils it's also in pet food I know it's
crazy so this is why it's so important
to start consuming organic so you can
avoid things like this right here so in
summary ideally you want to do grass-fed
grass-finished a hundred percent
certified organic if you could find it
now there are a couple companies online
that you can find the certification I
personally use a company u.s. wellness
meats I don't have any affiliation I
don't get any discounts or anything and
I really like that company because I
know the farm practices that they do
that the soils are really healthy and
the grass that the cows eat are super
healthy and I know the cows lived to
like 30 months typical factory farm cow
would live about 14 months okay so
basically double because it's hard to
fatten a cow on grass so you just have
to extend the life and this is why they
do the grain finish because the grains
actually can fatten the cattle so
finished means they can add some
additional product to fatten them for
about four months okay so if you're
gonna actually grass finish it could
take like ten months a lot longer anyway
I thought this was an important topic to
just differentiate between these
different terms alright thanks for
watching
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications